Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, der Trump, der will jetzt auch noch das Bildungsministerium auflösen.
We don't need no education.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 518 vom 23. März 2025.
Und ja, hier ist eure Begleitsendung auf dem Weg ins Orwellische Reich.
If you don't eat your meat, you can't have any pudding. How can you have any
pudding if you don't eat your meat?
Hast du das gesehen? Die Abschaffung, als er da wieder irgendwas unterschrieben
hat mit seinem Filzstift, dass er da irgendwie, hat der hinter sich so ein paar
Kinder mit Schulbänken aufgebaut.
Das ist einfach...
Ja.
Ah. Und das fällt mir nur jetzt gerade ein, müssen wir auch mit in die Sendung
aufnehmen. Wir haben es noch gar nicht in den Shownotes.
Die haben nebenbei noch den Open Tech Fund abgeschafft.
Wir hatten das vor einigen Jahren hier in der Sendung besprochen.
Der Open Technology Fund hat so Signal gefördert, also die frühe Entwicklung
von Signal, da hieß es sogar noch Red Phone,
weil ich auch immer wieder für den Open Tech Fund gearbeitet habe,
da auch die ganzen Leute kennengelernt von Signal schon vor vielen Jahren.
Und Tor haben sie stark gefördert und aktuell fördern sie so VPN,
andere sichere Messenger und so.
Das ist halt ein relativ guter und sehr gut gemanagter Fonds für letztendlich halt,
wie nennt man das, Freedom, Liberation Technology.
Also verschlüsselte Kommunikationssysteme, sichere Kommunikationssysteme oder
auch Verteilen von Informationen, sodass sie nicht mehr so einfach zensiert
werden können. Also all das, was passiert.
Eben in nicht so freien Ländern technisch dann durchaus eine Rolle spielen kann
und spielt, um an Zensur und Unterdrückung vorbeizukommen.
Die haben auf jeden Fall zweistelliges Millionenbudget, das da jedes Jahr in
solche Technologien fließt.
Und es wurde jetzt dann vor wenigen Tagen Bescheid gesagt, dass das Programm
halt abgeschossen wird.
Ja, es zu Vogue geht natürlich gar nicht.
Ja, ist auch hier wieder Interessenkonflikt. Wir arbeiten für die.
Also ich habe da jetzt tatsächlich gerade Schwierigkeiten, um zu gucken, ob...
Für wen jetzt? Für die Trump-Regierung? Für den Open-Tech-Fund?
Für den Open-Tech-Fund, ja. Haben mehrere Projekte für die gemacht,
in der Vergangenheit sowieso schon.
Also wir, dein, wir, nicht ich.
Ja, mein, wo ich mein Geld verdiene.
Genau.
Tagsüber, ich arbeite ja Tagsüber. Und das ist,
da arbeiten wir auch an Projekten für den Open Tech Fund, hauptsächlich Code
Audits und solche Sachen von anderen Projekten.
Früher habe ich da auch in Projekten mitgearbeitet, die selber quasi,
haben halt Sachen gebaut, nicht kaputt gemacht.
Jetzt machen wir nur Sachen kaputt und ja, muss ich mal gucken,
ob wir die geleistete Arbeit noch gezahlt bekommen, das will ich mal hoffen.
Aber so geplante Arbeiten werden wir dann sehen.
Sind wir getrumped worden?
Ja, ich würde es die europäische Chance nennen.
Ja, also die Programme in Deutschland, die den Sovereign Tech Fund und Prototype
Fund, die sind ja ganz klar vom OTF inspiriert.
Also die kennen uns ja auch daher und das wäre jetzt die Gelegenheit,
das zu übernehmen und sich die Erfolge dieser Projekte, die da gerade entwickelt werden,
in ein paar Jahren sich damit zu schmücken.
Ja genau, also das könnte in vielerlei Hinsicht Europa helfen,
weil erstens dadurch, dass du quasi bereits aktive Vorzeigeprojekte,
die auch bewiesen haben, dass sie sinnvoll sind,
die auch, sagen wir mal, im Rahmen eines solchen Funds auch beteiligen.
Gezeigt haben, dass sie entwickelt werden können. Das ist ja quasi das ideale,
Futter, weil wenn du jetzt beschließen würdest als EU, darauf das Geld zu werfen,
zu sagen so, ach ja, dann machen wir das halt, die 20 Millionen,
irgendwie scheiß drauf.
Da arbeiten ja viele Leute, die das auswählen, da hast du halt quasi das ganze
Wetting, die ganze Prüfung.
Das kannst du jetzt hingehen und sagen, jo, zack, hier kommt,
wie viel fehlt da? Gib mal hier doppeltes Geld, mach mal bitte fertig.
Also wird natürlich nicht ganz einfach werden, weil jetzt nicht alle Leute,
die da gearbeitet haben in den USA, bereit sind, dann in Deutschland zu arbeiten.
Müssen sie ja nicht. Kannst ja in den USA bleiben. Kann ja jeder in den USA bleiben.
Da muss die EU aber demnächst wahrscheinlich sich in den USA auch als ausländische
Agentenorganisation registriert werden.
Wie nennen die Russen das nochmal? Ja genau, sowas.
Also wir können den ja auch Rechnungen stellen, das funktioniert schon.
Ja klar, aber es soll ja letzten Endes, also erstmal würde es darum gehen zu
sagen, hier ausgestreckte Hand, wir finden das nach wie vor gut,
wir finanzieren euch jetzt erstmal weiter, ihr arbeitet jetzt erstmal,
keine Ahnung, fünf Jahre so weiter.
Sind die Projektförderungen da noch nicht mal?
Nee, es geht mir ums Team. Mir geht es ja ums Team, nicht um die geförderten
Projekte, sondern um die Struktur, solche Projekte zu fördern.
Deswegen meine ich ja gerade, wäre es ja für die Europäer ein doppelter Gewinn.
Weil du ja, also erstmal würdest du die Erfahrung des Teams bekommen und mit
denen natürlich dann möglichst dran arbeiten, zu sagen, okay,
ihr macht jetzt mal das, was ihr vorher gemacht habt.
Aber ihr macht bitte mal auch, Ihr baut quasi in Zusammenarbeit mit uns Europäern
den europäischen Teil auf.
Wir nehmen sozusagen eure learnings und setzen eine entsprechend globale Initiative um,
die dann ein bisschen europäischer zentriert, muss sie gar nicht mal sein,
aber eine europäische Geschmacksrichtung noch bekommt.
Und außerdem ...
Hast du auch gleich eben jetzt zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt Projekte,
die eben schon gezeigt haben, dass sie auch förderungswillig und fähig sind
und dadurch kann das eben auch gleich smooth laufen und man kann das dann verheiraten
mit europäischen Sachen und so weiter.
Ich bin schon wieder viel zu optimistisch, aber das wäre eine Gelegenheit.
Also überhaupt fällt eine ganze Menge runter und bevor jetzt die Chinesen anfangen,
das zu machen, glaube ich, wäre das bei uns besser aufgehoben.
Ja, also nur zum Kontext, das ist, also der Open Tech Fund ist ein Projekt der
US Agency for Global Media,
also diese Projekte, die entstehen müssen, im weitesten Sinne zielen die auf
Presse, Meinungs, Redefreiheit und den Schutz von JournalistInnen.
Daher der Fokus auf Verschlüsselung und oder Verbreitung von Informationen.
Und mit seinem Executive Order hat er jetzt gesagt, die Reduktion der Federal Bureaucracy.
Und dann hat er irgendwie eine Liste aufgegeben, wem er jetzt den Scope verkleinert,
was er alles nicht mehr machen muss.
Und da fällt dann tatsächlich the United States Agency for Global Media anstelle 2,
the Federal Mediation and Conciliation Service, the Institute of Museum and Library Services.
Also all sowas, was eine Kultur stärkt.
Gut, wollen wir dann mit dem Feedback anfangen?
Ja, ich finde es nicht gut, aber okay, fangen wir mit dem Feedback an.
Finde es nicht gut? Scheiß Feedback.
Nein, die Meldung, die ich jetzt gerade hier, die Information,
die ich gerade bekannt geben musste.
Na klar.
Und dann werde ich direkt noch korrigiert, ja. Habe ich was Falsches gesagt in der letzten Sendung?
Und zwar habe ich.
Gesagt, der Bill Gates sei auf der Inauguration von Donald Trump gewesen.
Und da korrigiert Robert, moin, danke für die sehr unterhaltsame und informative
Folge, aber ich muss eine kleine Korrektur anmerken.
Bill Gates war nicht bei der Amtseinführung von Trump. Er hat sogar darüber gelästert.
Zusätzlich hat er auch noch eine große Spende während des Wahlkampfs an Kamala
Harris gegeben. Und das stimmt, es war niemand von Microsoft da,
auch nicht Satya Nadella bei der Inauguration.
Satya Nadella war beim World Economic Forum zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Allerdings hat Microsoft eine Million zu diesem Inauguration Fund dazugeworfen.
Und der Präsident von Microsoft, Brad Smith, hat eine Reception for Cabinet
Members besucht, die von dem J.D.
Vance veranstaltet wurde.
Aber die anderen Leute, ich habe jetzt nochmal geschaut, der,
wie heißt der, Sundar Pichar, der war da.
Musk, Musk, Zuckerberg und sind schon alle da gewesen.
Aber Gates ist stabil geblieben.
Hätte man sich auch nicht, also so Bill Gates erinnern, dass das der Typ nochmal,
ich meine, der war wirklich Jahrzehnte mein absolutes Bild von Böse.
Und dann wird der auf einmal, auf einmal ist die Welt so schief geraten,
dass das einer von den Guten ist.
Ja, Also bei Gates, da muss ich sagen, da habe ich ja von meinem,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Hass nennen kann, aber von meiner Abneigung habe
ich schon vor einiger Zeit abgeschworen.
Der ist wirklich gut bereift.
Wann war es, als er versucht hat, Krankheiten zu heilen mit seinen Milliarden, die uns alle töten?
Oder an welchem Moment hast du nochmal dein Bild von Bill Gates korrigiert?
Naja gut, sagen wir mal so, meine persönliche, ich habe ihn jetzt nicht für
den Antichrist gehalten,
aber er war natürlich in den 80er Jahren einerseits so ein bisschen die Antithese
zur Open Source Bewegung,
der er sicher auch, sagen wir mal.
Und sehr früh in seiner Karriere hat er für Bezahlung für Software plädiert.
Ich habe mir gerade dieses Source Code, heißt das Buch, seine Beginne,
seine Anfänge, wie er dann Microsoft gegründet hat.
Ja, ja, hat ja auch letzten Endes zur Begründung seines Imperiums beigetragen.
Ansonsten war er bei mir persönlich immer quasi für Windows verantwortlich.
Da hat sich meine Meinung bis heute nicht nennenswert geändert.
Aber er ist dann eben spätestens, nachdem er eigentlich aktiv aus der Firma
rausgegangen ist, nur noch sehr positiv eigentlich aufgetreten.
Also er hat so viel Geld in Malaria-Forschung zum Beispiel gesteckt und viele andere Sachen auch.
Und naja, dass er irgendwie halbwegs geradeaus ist, das zeigt ja jetzt auch
dieser Kommentar, der ist definitiv der Anti-Mask.
Ja.
Aber selten, ein seltener Schlag in Silicon Valley. Die meisten haben dann doch
eher die Dollarzeichen in den Augen.
Und Gates hat ja eigentlich relativ früh gesagt, dass er halt seine ganze Kohle
auch wieder wegspenden will.
Ja, okay, war nicht da.
Und kriegt es okay von uns.
Ja.
Bill? Entschuldigung.
Entschuldigung. Sorry.
Latt uns mal wieder ein.
Jetzt musst du nur noch diese Windows-Nummer gerade machen.
Dann das kriegen die nicht hin.
Dann wird er in die Sendung eingeladen.
Windows bleibt das Betriebssystem des schlechten Geschmacks.
Daran wird sich, glaube ich, nichts ändern.
Allein schon, dass der OK-Button links ist und der Cancell-Button rechts.
Das ist einfach, mehr muss man nicht zu sagen. Aber egal. Lass uns weitermachen.
Ich glaube, der Okay-Button gehört nach links. Also Erich Klotz hat ja hier
auch noch was zu links und rechts.
Erich Klotz hat ja was zu links und rechts.
Ich würde sagen, rechts canceln.
Links, okay. Du meinst, Windows ist die wahre Antifa? Oh Mann.
Mach mich fertig.
Lest mal vor.
Wieso, da wirst du korrigiert. Nee, keine Ahnung.
Wir haben eine Links-Rechts-Diskussion geführt und da gab es dann von Erich
noch einen Hinweis für den moralpolitischen Kompass.
Das Konzept Links-Rechts kommt ja aus der französischen Revolution,
wo links im Parlament die Leute saßen, die Zwei-Klassengesellschaft schlecht
fanden und Gleichberechtigung, Menschenrechte und Demokratie haben wollten.
Rechts saßen die anderen, die Zweiklassengesellschaft gut fanden und deswegen
auch Gleichberechtigung, Demokratie und Menschenrechte ablehnten.
Deswegen tendenziell immer links. Außer man ist Millionär oder mehr.
Deswegen links okay, rechts Ganze.
Ja, okay. Pass auf. Es geht nicht darum, dass es immer rechts ist,
sondern es geht sozusagen, dass es an der an der Ecke des Fensters ist.
Wenn du jetzt das im Arabischen hast, dann kann der OK-Button natürlich auch
links sein, aber dann ist er halt auch links in der Ecke.
Darum geht es.
Also ich bin mir überhaupt nicht, also ich ehrlich gesagt glaube,
dass du ohnehin Unsinn redest, weil ich habe nicht den Eindruck,
dass Windows überhaupt ein einheitliches UI ist.
Da hast du auch einen Punkt, aber an der Stelle.
Das ist mir bisher nicht aufgefallen.
Dass es da irgendwelche Regeln gibt. Es kann nicht komplett random sein,
weil dafür sehe ich es einfach zu oft falsch.
Es müsste ja dann zumindest eine Hälfte der Fälle richtig sein.
Das wiederum, also kann Spuren von linken OK-Buttons enthalten, glaube ich, ist okay.
Na gut, dann schauen wir doch mal nach rechts.
Oder ist es links? Man weiß es nicht so ganz genau. Neue Bundesregierung Anteportas
hat sich jetzt ein wenig durchsetzen können im Bundestag,
allerdings im alten Bundestag. Wo?
Hatte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt mit gerechnet, weil ich das Prozedere nicht
gut genug kannte, wie ich ja schon in der letzten Sendung auch nachgewiesen
bekommen habe. habe ich schon keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall wurde ein Beschluss gefasst mit der Zweidrittelmehrheit im Bundestag, die sich halt aus CDU,
ich weiß nicht, hat die FDP auch dafür gestimmt eigentlich?
Würde mich sehr wundern, oder? Wenn die FDP, also ich meine.
Der FDP wundert mich eh immer alles, also ich weiß es nicht,
auf jeden Fall die Grünen.
Also das wäre ein neuer eine neue ein neuer ein neuer,
Punkt auf der ...
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ich hätte es nicht ansprechen sollen.
Das zeigt ja jetzt nur, dass wir uns das nicht genau genug angeschaut haben.
Auf jeden Fall habt ihr es ja auch alle mitbekommen. Und jetzt haben wir den
Beschluss, dass Deutschland nicht mehr diese Schuldenbremse,
die vorher im Grundgesetz stand, so einhalten muss, sondern dass es da jetzt mehr Freiheiten gibt.
Und das bedeutet, dass jetzt ein größerer,
dreistelliger Milliardenbetrag in Infrastruktur ...
In die Zukunft investiert werden kann.
In die Zukunft investiert werden kann und ein noch viel höherer Betrag,
nämlich unbegrenzt viel Schulden dürften, darf gemacht werden für die militärische
Aufrüstung in Deutschland.
Und das ist natürlich ein Befreiungsschlag für die nächste Bundesregierung,
die ja dann sozusagen überhaupt erstmal sich zusammenfinden muss.
Dazu muss der neue Bundestag erstmalig einberufen werden.
Es muss ein Kanzler gewählt und eine Regierung gestellt werden.
Und naja, so weit sind wir ja noch nicht. Da wird ja noch drüber diskutiert.
Und dieser gesamte Vorgang, der im Ergebnis enorm positiv ist,
wurde natürlich zu Recht mit kritischer Stimme begleitet.
Ja, zwar erstens ist festzuhalten, dass der Friedrich Merz sich schon sehr klar
in seinen Kanzlerduellen und was nicht alles kritisch zu dem Gedanken geäußert hat,
Schulden aufzunehmen.
Er hat jetzt nicht spezifisch, also wird sicherlich,
das weiß ich nicht genau, ob er ein konkretes Wahlversprechen in der Richtung
hat, aber seine Kommunikation war sehr eindeutig, dass er gesagt hat,
ich höre immer nur Schulden, wo soll das Geld herkommen, die armen Kinder haben dann und so weiter.
Das war schon sehr klar, auch in diesem Kanzlerduell, was ich da geschaut habe.
Sodass dieser gesamte Wahlkampf der CDU erinnert,
hier durch diese richtige Entscheidung, die nicht richtigen,
aber dennoch geäußerten und vielleicht auch für einige wählende Personen entscheidenden
Wahlversprechen der CDU gebrochen wurden.
Allerdings haben die das ja auch gesagt, das machen sie dann,
wenn sie an der Regierung sind, so oder nicht. Die sind ja noch gar nicht an der Regierung.
Insofern kann man jetzt quasi sagen, die haben das Wahlversprechen noch gar
nicht gebrochen, weil es ist ja noch vor dem Wahlergebnis, also vor der Umsetzung
des Wahlergebnisses, da durften sie das dann machen.
Aber der Wahlkampf war relativ klar, dass da niemand gesagt hat,
hier, wir finanzieren das jetzt hier ordentlich mit Schulden.
Und es ist trotzdem richtig, das zu tun.
Das, was es auch so ein bisschen schwierig gemacht hat, einerseits zu sagen,
was ist eine Wahlversprochen, was ist eine Wahlaussage, was ist ein Wahlkampf
von Friedrich Merz wert?
Andererseits so, naja, zumindest haben sie jetzt gemeinsam etwas Sinnvolles entschieden.
Aber ich wollte es zumindest sagen, dass den Punkt, den hat Friedrich Merz nicht verdient.
Dafür hat er auf jeden Fall früher nicht argumentiert.
Denk doch mal an die SPD. Die sind jetzt vom Staat weg nicht die Umfallerpartei.
Das ist doch auch mal schön für die.
Aber ja, natürlich, also Krisen kriegst du auf, oder Schulden machst du für
die Zukunft und schuldenfrei in eine Zukunft zu gehen, ist völliger Unsinn.
Und natürlich machst du Schulden in der Wahrnehmung oder in der Hoffnung oder in der Aussicht,
dass du sie irgendwann wieder abbaust, beziehungsweise dass du sie halt durch
Zinsen und Raten es für alle interessant machst,
diese Schulden aufrecht zu erhalten.
Und das ist das Richtige, dass es grundsätzlich etwas Sinnvolles ist und das
Arbiträr zu begrenzen über Kriegssituationen in Europa und Pandemien hinweg
ist keine besonders gute Idee gewesen.
Nö, man hätte natürlich auch mal drüber nachdenken können, ob man es nicht einfach
mal von den Reichen nimmt, aber das wäre natürlich jetzt für die CDU dann doch radikal gewesen.
Jetzt wäre man nicht frech.
Ja, Entschuldigung.
So, jetzt wollen die sich aber konsolidieren und ihre Ministeriumszusammensetzung neu definieren.
Und man hört, man hört, oh oh oh oh, dass Trommelwirbel, Trommelwirbel, Trommelwirbel.
Digitalministerium, lass mich raten.
Ja, ein Digitalministerium eingeführt werden soll.
Das wurde hier wahrscheinlich in dieser Sendung schon vor 518 Folgen gefordert.
Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau.
Naja, jedes Mal, wenn eine neue Regierung sich mit dem Gedanken rumspielt.
Zu konsolidieren, dann hatten wir das Thema auf die eine oder andere Art und
Weise. Mit anderen Worten, den Gedanken begrüßen wir.
Jetzt muss natürlich erstmal ausgeknobelt werden, wie viele Ministerien es denn überhaupt geben soll.
Man will kein weiteres, sondern man möchte ein anderes, aber man möchte kein weiteres.
Das heißt, es wird wohl diskutiert, entweder das Entwicklungshilfeministerium
beim Außenministerium einzugliedern,
wo es Argumente für und dagegen gibt und man könnte natürlich auch dieses Bauministerium,
was die Ampel erst eingeführt hat, was eh nicht viel gebaut hat,
natürlich auch woanders eingliedern, irgendwas wird passieren.
Aber die eigentliche Frage ist ja, wenn es denn ein digitales Ministerium gibt,
zwei Fragen habe ich da vor allem.
Erstens, was machen die dann?
Zweitens, wem dürfen die reinreden? Und drittens, wer?
Wer stellt dieses Ministerium, also welche politische Führung bekommt dieses
Ministerium, wenn ihr mir jetzt wieder mit der CSU kommt, dann gibt es Ärger.
Also das kann einfach, ja, also das,
wenn jetzt die hier wieder ihre Laptops und Lederhosen-Nummer,
ich sehe es aber schon kommen, also vielleicht am besten noch so ein Vollhorst
wie Dobrindt oder so. Der ist ja immer noch da.
Also da sehe ich so ein bisschen schwarz, aber lassen wir das erstmal außen
vor, wer sich da dann lächerlich macht.
Die eigentliche Frage ist, was genau soll ein Digitalministerium tun sollen,
müssen, können, dürfen und eben diese zweite Frage, ich weiß nicht,
ob du das verstanden hast, was ich gesagt habe, äh,
auf welche anderen Ministerien hat dieses Ministerium...
Darf das einwirken, ja.
Genau, weil zum Beispiel gibt es ja das Finanzministerium...
Du hattest das ja mal den Digitalvorbehalt, hattest du das nicht hier schon mal formuliert?
Ja, genau, das ist ein Begriff, glaube ich, den ich mal abfallen lassen.
Im Sinne von, so wie das Finanzministerium Entscheidungen anderer Ministerien
blockieren oder beeinflussen kann, weil die können natürlich alles Mögliche
planen, aber wenn die dafür kein Budget bekommen, dann geht das halt nicht.
Und das war quasi mein Gedanke, dass ein Digitalministerium sagt,
wir planen jetzt mal hier den digitalen Start.
Wir wollen also, dass alles zugänglich ist.
Wir wollen, dass möglichst alle Dienstleistungen auch digital abrufbar sind
oder nutzbar sind. Also digital im Sinne von online.
Und wir eben über eine solide und grundsätzliche Digitalisierung von allem nachdenken.
Und wie das halt nicht laufen darf, meiner Meinung nach ist,
dass man jetzt im alten Stil halt an irgendwelche… Ich könnte ein Leuchtturmprojekt machen. Genau.
Wie so Autobahn-Maut-mäßig Kohle raushauen, dann wird dann fünf Jahre von irgendeiner
Firma dran rumgemunkelt und zwei Wochen vorher, bevor es laufen soll,
sagen die dann so, ja, nee, geht nicht.
Hat aber das dreifache gekostet. Aber die Berater haben gut verdient.
Dafür brauchen wir kein Digitalministerium. Also Kohle rausschmeißen,
das konnten die anderen vorher auch schon ganz gut.
Das muss halt anders organisiert sein und weiß nicht, vielleicht haben wir ja
nochmal so ein paar Leitgedanken, die man hier einwerfen könnte,
falls jemand zuhört, der gerade an einer Koalition und an einem Ministeriumsdesign fahre.
Ich will einfach, das Einzige, was ich mir wünsche, keine Leuchtturmprojekte.
Das ist schon alles. Und zwar, ich glaube, ich habe das hier im Podcast schon
mal öfter behandelt, ich glaube, in der letzten Digitalstrategie gab es 26 20 Leuchtturmprojekte.
Und ich hatte, glaube ich, auch schon mal ausgeführt, dass der Leuchtturm als
architektonische Metapher schon zeigt, dass das, was man da baut,
Wahrscheinlich nicht das ist, was man haben möchte. Also ein Leuchtturm.
Ein Anwendungsfall. Und dieser Anwendungsfall des Leuchtturms ist,
möglichst auf große Distanz zu sagen, hier nicht hin.
Hier nicht hin. Das ist die in Stein gegossene Aussage eines Leuchtturms.
Bitte weiträumig meiden. Gefahr. Und die sagen halt, wir machen digitales Leuchtturm. Projekt.
Und dann wundern die sich, dass alle drum rum fahren.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal so der Aspekt.
Wirklich die architektonische Eignung des Leuchtturms macht man auch gar nicht mehr.
Okay, das ist definitiv etwas, was wir nicht brauchen. Weil das auch,
Leuchtturmprojekte heißt im Wesentlichen auch, da arbeitet dann eine separierte
Gruppe eine Weile vor sich hin und versucht irgendwie einen Dicken zu machen.
Strebt nach oben. Ist mit niemandem koordiniert.
Warum es mir ginge bei einem Digitalministerium ist, dass man einfach erstmal
solid, also erstmal braucht man natürlich einen soliden Personal stammen.
Da müssen wirklich erfahrene Menschen rein und möglichst wenig Politiker.
Da braucht es einfach mal Leute, die von Digitalisierung wirklich Ahnung haben,
die vielleicht auch nicht so richtig Bock drauf haben, sich jetzt in so eine
politische Struktur reinzusetzen. Da muss man auf jeden Fall Wege finden.
Wäre für so ein neues Ministerium auf jeden Fall auch eine Chance,
hier mal anders gedacht zu werden. Wir haben ja mit dem,
Sprint,
dem Projekt für Sprunginnovationen.
Ja, die Agentur für Sprunginnovationen.
Die Agentur für Sprunginnovationen. Schon ein ganz interessantes Modell,
wo man sicherlich sich das ein oder andere abschauen kann.
Aber vor allem geht es meiner Meinung nach darum, einfach mal solide einen digitalen Start zu planen.
Und das ist sicherlich nichts, was von heute auf morgen stattfinden kann.
Aber es muss eben Inhouse geschehen und man muss mit modernen Methoden erstmal
analysieren, okay, alles klar, wie machen andere Staaten das?
Was sind sozusagen die besten Lösungen und Ansätze, die am meisten Erfolg hatten
bisher, die am besten funktionieren?
Welche technischen Lösungen gibt es da? Was gibt es auch vielleicht schon an Open Source?
Was kann man vielleicht auch einfach nutzen? Oder zumindest sich in Protokollen,
Abläufen, Strukturen etc. abschauen.
Und dann natürlich das Ganze umlegen. Und ein Problem, was ich natürlich sehe,
ist der Föderalismus in Deutschland.
Dass wir eben für alles irgendwie 16 verschiedene Umsetzungen haben.
Das kann man zwar auch in Software abbilden, aber ich finde,
hier muss es auch einen Trend geben, dass so ein Digitalministerium sagt, hör mal,
hier um Problem X geht.
Zu lösen, wo wir so viel Aufgabenhoheit in den Ländern haben,
da müssen wir einen Kompromiss finden.
Da muss es in irgendeiner Form eine Standardisierung geben.
Da muss es in irgendeiner Form eine Möglichkeit geben, dass nicht hier jeder
seinen eigenen Quatsch macht und nichts mit nichts kompatibel ist.
Es gibt ja auch Bereiche, wo Softwareentwicklung schon in der Hand des Staates ist.
Wo es so leidlich gut funktioniert. Das ist dieser ganze Steuerbereich.
Wenn es ums Geld geht, da wird man dann ja auch immer etwas schneller kreativ.
Und da gibt es ja tatsächlich schon größere Gruppen, die halt wirklich an dieser
ganzen Elster-Software, Zoll-Software und so weiter entwickeln.
Das ist jetzt nichts komplett Neues.
Und diese ganze Kompetenz muss natürlich dann in das Ministerium geholt werden.
Wobei ich damit jetzt nicht sagen will, dass alle anderen Ministerien von ihren
digitalen Kompetenzen entbunden werden sollen.
Sondern da muss man natürlich einen guten Weg finden, wie man da entweder eine
Transition macht oder eben auch eine Koexistenz macht.
Weil letzten Endes müssen natürlich auch dann die einzelnen Ministerien in der
Lage sein, ihren Kram selber umzusetzen. Sollen die ruhig weiter dafür zuständig sein?
Es geht ja nur darum, dass man eine Kollaboration über alles hinweg zentral
plant und eben diesen Digitalvorbehalt formulieren kann.
Dass man sagen kann, ihr könnt jetzt hier nicht einfach irgendwo hin marschieren,
liebes Bundesland X, sondern ihr müsst euch hier schon so ein bisschen an unsere
Guidelines halten, weil wir haben ja hier ein langfristiges Ziel und das wollen wir gerne haben.
Wenn ein langfristiges Ziel ist, dass der OK-Button rechts ist.
Genau, an der Ecke.
Einheitliche.
An der Ecke muss er sein. Der OK-Button muss an der Ecke sein.
Das ist das, worum es geht. Links oder rechts? Ist egal.
Wir schreiben ja auch unsere Zahlen andersrum.
Tja, ich habe gerade überlegt, wer mir denn da einfiele, wer in Frage kommt.
Und tatsächlich sieht es natürlich, also wer da diskutiert, ich glaube,
ich bin in keiner der beiden Parteien ausreichend gut beläumundet.
Also Nina Starr war im Digital- oder ist wahrscheinlich, gibt es ja noch die,
ist im Digitalausschuss für die SPD.
Saskia Esken.
Ist ja Informatikerin.
Informatikerin, hat sich im Bereich Bildung, Open Source und so durchaus beschäftigt.
Interessiert.
Dann gibt es noch Dirk Wiese und Jens Zimmermann, die eher so Breitbandausbau,
digitale Infrastruktur, Verwaltung, vielleicht Plattformregulierung so ein bisschen behandeln.
Bei der CDU gibt es Nadine Schön, die hat für Digitales der Bundestagsfraktion gesprochen.
Thomas Jatzvombeck, der ist sicherlich auch schon relativ lange im Bundestag,
den kenne ich relativ lange zumindest. Zumindest der ist aber eher so Gründerförderung,
KI, Digitalisierung der Verwaltung sind so Themen.
Und dann gibt es Ronja Kemmer, die als CDU-Digitalpolitikerin der jungen Generation,
also wahrscheinlich U60 ist und auch im Ausschuss für Digital ist.
Der Name sagt mir nichts, müsste ich jetzt gucken.
Das ist mir bisher noch nicht aufgefallen. Und dann gibt es noch Marc Henrichmann,
der sich mit Regulierung von sozialen Netzwerken.
Also da sind bisher nicht so Profile bei,
bis auf Thomas Jatz-Hombeck, muss ich wirklich sagen, die mir bisher als mutig
und mit eigenen Ideen in dem Bereich aufgefallen sind.
Also bei der CDU wäre es dann Thomas Jatz-Hombeck, der das zumindest seit längerer
Zeit behandelt. Position, nochmal ein anderes Thema.
Und bei der SPD dann Saskia Esken.
Wenn diese Personen das Potenzial hätten, dieses Land zu retten,
hätten sie es bis jetzt wahrscheinlich gemacht.
Man könnte natürlich noch überlegen, ob man das irgendwie an die Scheuer,
könnte man nochmal fragen.
Jens Spahn wird ja sicherlich auch wieder im Posten haben wollen.
Und Dobrindt.
Dobrindt, ja. Aber Dobrindt war doch schon mal. Der hat das damals schon gut gemacht.
Er hat ja damals schon gut vor die Wand gefahren. Den könnte man eigentlich noch mal,
so eine 90-Grad-Kehrtwende machen und gegen die nächste Wand fahren.
Ja, oder einfach mal gar keinen Parteipolitiker. Einfach mal jemanden, der sich auskennt.
Deswegen habe ich das ja, also um dein Argument, dass man vielleicht mal,
warum nicht mal jemand, der sich auskennt, habe ich ja mal unterstützt mit dieser Auswahl.
Ja gut, Digitalministerium. Währenddessen,
also hier, wie heißt dieser Innenminister von NRW? Herbert Reul.
Also auch irgendwie aus dem Nichts, da fragt man sich auf, ob die Süddeutsche
Zeitung nichts zu tun hat.
Ein großes Interview, Reul, Vorratsdatenspeicherung wegen der ganzen Terroristen
und Kindesmissbrauch und so im Internet, ganz schlimm alles und er will jetzt
Vorratsdatenspeicherung wieder haben,
das heißt, das Thema wird dann natürlich auch wieder kommen,
dann können die wieder nach Grazruhe, können die wieder an die Europäische Union
und was nicht alles da vortanzen, hat ja Nancy Faeser auch gemacht,
also das heißt, da wird auch unser,
täglich Brot hier gesichert für Lockbuch Netzpolitik, dass da so unsere All-Star-Themen,
die wir seit der ersten Sendung haben, dass da auch eine Kontinuität bleiben kann.
Ja.
Alles wie immer.
Und was haben wir noch? Ja, vorhin Digitalministerium.
Also es setzt sich nach, jetzt sagen wir ungefähr,
wie lange geht es eigentlich, wie lange wäre jetzt Internet,
also wie lange hat sich in Deutschland die Erkenntnis etabliert,
dass das Internet keine Spielerei für Computerfreaks ist, in der man keine Zukunft sieht.
Und um jetzt hier mal den Telekom-Chef noch mal zu paraphrasieren.
Ich habe so den Eindruck, dass alle vom Internet sprechen, ist jetzt doch schon
durchaus so, könnte man sagen, so ein Vierteljahrhundert.
Wir haben ja 2025 jetzt.
So 2000 war so eine Zeit, da hatte jede Person dann so gesagt,
was ist eigentlich das mit diesem Internet?
Moment, das scheint sich ja vielleicht doch entgegen aller Unkenrufe zu etablieren.
Vielleicht muss ich da auch mal gucken. Ich würde jetzt sagen so ein Vierteljahrhundert, oder?
Also vor 25 Jahren, das ist glaube ich kurz vor dem New Economy Crash gewesen.
Na gut, aber das heißt, es hat sich für alle rumgesprochen und sie haben auch
gesagt, alles klar, da werfen wir jetzt Geld rein.
Genau, dann kaufen wir jetzt mal Aktien, die dann ein halbes Jahr später nichts mehr wert waren.
Ja, das kam so graduell, aber du hast schon recht, so 25 Jahre ist das Thema
jetzt eigentlich auf der Agenda, jetzt könnten wir langsam mal was machen.
Das Thema ist ein Schwelbrand.
Jetzt könnten wir langsam mal was machen, aber erwähnst du das jetzt noch mal
im Zusammenhang mit dem Ministerium oder im Zusammenhang mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
Mit dem Ministerium.
Ja. Ja, also ich meine, man kann ja, das,
Das könnte ja auch funktionieren, ja.
Wen könnte man denn nehmen? Hasso Plattner.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Es gibt sicherlich pfiffige Leute, keine Ahnung,
ich bin kein Politberater. Ich kritze nur rum.
Aber du, also es wird wieder gemischt mit einem anderen, ja,
also wieder Verkehr, digitale Infrastruktur oder?
Also es gibt da noch keinen Beschluss, ich habe nur gelesen,
dass sie halt, wenn sie ein komplett neues Ministerium schaffen damit,
dass sie die Zahl der Ministerien insgesamt reduzieren wollen.
Aber ich denke mal, sie können jetzt nicht ein Digitalministerium starten und
dann die Kompetenz fürs Digitale auf fünf verschiedene Ministerien legen,
wie sie das ja schon mal war.
Wirtschaftsministerium, Verkehrsministerium und was war das dritte?
Stimmt, das war auch schön.
Wirtschaft, Verkehr und noch irgendwas. Ich habe es vergessen.
Das hat auch super funktioniert.
War eh klar.
Wenn du das an mehrere verteilst, dann hast du einen wunderschönen Effekt,
der sich als Verantwortungsdiffusion bezeichnet.
Das heißt, entweder tut keiner,
Oder alle gleichzeitig. Jedenfalls kriegst du kein vernünftiges Ergebnis.
Aber das sehen wir ja jetzt auch.
Wen könnte man denn? Also wen könnte man nehmen, der dann auch noch für eine SPD-CDU,
Ulrich Kälber.
Was jetzt noch so ein Datenschutz-Spezie reinholen?
Naja, der hat ja schon durchaus, also Ulrich Kälber hatte ja schon ein gesundes
Verständnis von Informatik und so.
Er hat ja auch sehr häufig sich darüber aufgeregt, dass dem Datenschutz die Schuld gegeben wird,
obwohl es die tatsächliche Schuld
dabei lag, dass man einfach bescheuerte Lösungen versucht hat zu bauen.
Und hat da ja durchaus sein Verständnis von IT,
in diesen Diskussionen, in diesen Gesprächen zu demonstriert.
Wir brauchen, ich glaube, wir sind über diesen Punkt hinaus,
wo wir händeringend überhaupt erstmal jemanden finden müssen,
der Verständnis für IT hat.
Ich meine, da waren wir auch schon mal bei Dorothee Bär, die dafür gefeiert
wurde, dass sie einen Twitter-Account hatte.
Damit war sie der Leuchtturm in der CDU.
Du hast gerade einen wunderschönen Versprecher gehabt.
Nämlich, dass du gesagt hast, wir suchen jemanden mit Verständnis für IT.
Das stimmt aber nicht. Wir suchen jemanden mit Verständnis von IT.
Und Doro Bär hatte Verständnis für IT. die hatte Verständnis für IT ja die hat
dafür allgemeines Verständnis gehabt so die hat das.
Ja du hast recht,
komm lass uns weitermachen,
Wir müssen eigentlich mal auf etwas hinweisen, was wir meiner Meinung nach sträflich
übersehen haben in den letzten zwei Monaten, nämlich die… Ja, Apple.
Nein.
Genau, Apple, es wird ja überhaupt viel zu wenig darüber diskutiert.
Könnte man mal einen Podcast drüber machen. Es geht überhaupt gar nicht um Apple.
Es geht um UK und zwar, wie wir ja alle wissen, sind ja die Briten schon immer.
So ein bisschen schärfer drauf gewesen, was so Krypto-Gesetze betrifft.
Und wollten schon immer so ein bisschen ran an Speck.
Und es gibt tatsächlich seit 2016 den Investigatory Powers Act,
der halt schon so einige Massenüberwachungselemente geschaffen hat.
Damals eben von den Tories umgesetzt.
Und letztes Jahr hat der auch nochmal ein Amendment, Investigatory Powers Amendment Act erhalten.
Investigatory Powers, muss man dazu sagen, ist immer dieser Geheimdienst- und
Polizeiteil bei den Briten.
Da gibt es ja auch das Investigatory Powers Tribunal, das ist dann das Geheimgericht,
bei dem geguckt wird, dass die Anordnungen alle geheim bleiben oder so.
Das war in den Snowden-Geschichten öfters mal Thema oder in der Folge dessen.
So, und jetzt haben die also den Investigatory Powers Act, wenn man den ändert,
dann heißt das im Zweifelsfall, die haben neue Befugnisse gegeben, oder?
Ja, aber es handelt sich, also ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt,
ich habe den jetzt nochmal in der kurzen Recherche jetzt nicht explizit gefunden,
was da drin benannt worden ist. Es geht jetzt auch erstmal um etwas anderes.
Also zunächst einmal noch ein Hinweis, Man nennt diesen Act,
diesen ursprünglichen Act, den bezeichnet man als Snoopers Starter.
Das ist so der Spitzname, den das Ganze bekommen hat und da gibt es auch diverse
Gruppen, die sich versuchen dagegen einzusetzen in UK.
Und jetzt gab es allerdings die Berichte einer Verschärfung.
Und das ist halt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne jetzt so ein Gesetz,
sondern das ist so eine geheime Anordnung, die halt Unternehmen dann mitgeteilt
wird, dass sie doch jetzt gefälligst dieses und jenes zu tun oder zu lassen haben.
Eine sogenannte Technical Capability Notice und es wurde gemunkelt,
berichtet, dass Apple unter anderem eine solche erhalten hat.
Und kurz gesagt wird in dieser Notice die Forderung gestellt,
dass die Unternehmen, wenn sie Daten über Kunden haben, in der Lage sein müssen,
Schlüssel dafür rauszugeben, dass halt die Investigatory Powers im Zweifelsfall
darauf zugreifen können, wenn was ganz Schlimmes passiert, wie Terrorismus.
Oder vorher schon natürlich.
Oder man hat was Böses gesagt gegen den Politiker oder sowas.
Also wir wissen alle, wie das läuft, aber das ist halt Terrorismus ist halt irgendwie der Grund.
Und Terrorismus ist manchmal auch ein ganz guter Grund, weil klar,
das kann man ja verstehen,
geht irgendwie eine Bedrohung aus von irgendeiner Person, die,
sagen wir mal, signifikant ist, dann gibt es natürlich den Wunsch,
da möglichst viel drüber zu erfahren.
Und die Forderung, und das ist ja auch mit dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung immer
wieder dasselbe Thema, da stehen sich so zwei Seiten gegenüber.
Die eine sagt, es kann ja nicht sein, dass wir an sowas nicht rankommen,
wenn es das gibt, weil das könnte uns ja helfen.
Und die andere Seite sagt, na, wenn wir aber das Fass aufmachen,
dann haben wir gleich ganz viele andere Probleme auch noch und genau in diesem
Battle befinden sich jetzt quasi UK und Apple,
denn Apple hat, also erstmal ist es so,
wenn du jetzt, es geht jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur um Apple,
ich kann das jetzt aber nur aus der Perspektive Apple berichten,
weil darüber viel berichtet wurde.
Und man kann davon ausgehen, dass das im Prinzip alle erhalten haben in irgendeiner Form.
Und jetzt ist es halt so, wenn Dienstleister X Daten für dich vorhält und da
gibt es in irgendeiner Form einen ungesicherten Zugang dazu,
Dann kann UK wohl diese Dienstleister,
so sie denn in UK operieren oder es sich um UK-Kunden handelt,
sagen, jetzt wollen wir da aber mal ran, gib mal her.
Auch wenn da eine Verschlüsselung vorliegt. Solange es einen Schlüssel gibt,
dann muss der sozusagen rausgerückt werden.
Und die Unternehmen dürfen aber auch nicht darüber reden. Das heißt,
damit ist so eine Gagorder verbunden.
Die dürfen also nicht sagen, weil die uns jetzt gesagt haben,
dass wir das jetzt tun und lassen sollen, müssen wir jetzt hier handeln,
sondern sie dürfen noch nicht mal darüber reden.
Etwas, was in den USA, du hast den Begriff Gag Order da gerade benannt,
also die Schweigeanordnung, was in den USA mit dem, wie heißen die,
National Security Letter, also eine geheime Anordnung zur Überwachung und die
hat Apple bekommen, für was?
Was sollte Apple entschlüsseln können?
Naja, alles wahrscheinlich. Natürlich. Das Ding ist nur, damit werden sie quasi
auch gezwungen, alles, was du für einen Kunden speicherst, rauszurücken.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn du einen Dienst hast, wo das nicht geht,
hast du einen Konflikt. Und so einen Dienst hat Apple, das ist nämlich diese
sogenannte Advanced Data Protection,
über die wir hier auch schon mal gesprochen haben vor einiger Zeit.
Dabei handelt es sich quasi um eine zusätzliche Absicherung deines Apple-Accounts,
deines iCloud-Accounts.
Nee, du musst ja schon erklären, dass es vielleicht was iCloud ist.
Also iCloud ist quasi der Name für all die ganzen Speicherdienste,
also Dateiablagerung, wo deine ganzen Fotos sind etc.
IMessage, Nachrichten, also was auch immer du alles in der Cloud bei Apple speicherst,
was halt eben in einem einzigen Account bei Apple, deinem Apple-Account abgelegt ist.
All das hat je nach Dienst mehr oder weniger Verschlüsselung.
Also es gibt sozusagen nochmal separat einzeln unterverschlüsselte Bereiche,
wie zum Beispiel die Messages.
Aber an vielen Dingen muss ja Apple auch ran.
Und also Fotos und so weiter, Syncing, all diese ganzen Sachen.
Es gibt jetzt allerdings die Möglichkeit seit einiger Zeit, Die sogenannte Advanced
Data Protection einzuschalten.
Und die Advanced Data Protection heißt, du verzichtest auf die Möglichkeit,
dass Apple dir, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel deine Keys verloren hast…,
also deine Passwörter vergessen hast, dass sie dir den Zugang theoretisch wiederherstellen können.
Wenn du also Advanced Data Protection einschaltest, dann kann Apple selbst gar
nicht mehr an die Daten ran.
Es sei denn, du loggst dich ein mit deinen Credentials.
Das ist einfach eine Verschlüsselung.
Das ist eine Vollverschlüsselung, genau, wo Apple keinen Key mehr hat,
also keinen mehr vorhält.
Und weil diese Verfügung jetzt in UK von Apple aber fordert,
dass sie so etwas haben, haben sie diesen Dienst für UK-Kunden eingestellt.
Das Feature gibt es nicht mehr, ja. Und was machen sie mit denen,
die das schon aktiviert hatten?
Also du kannst quasi nicht mehr, wenn du dich da jetzt anmeldest und sagst,
ich hätte gerne Advanced Data
Protection, sagen sie, dieser Dienst ist in deinem Land nicht verfügbar.
Genau. Und wenn du schon hattest, dann hast du es. Weil das können sie gar nicht
rückgängig machen. Das kannst du dir nur selber machen.
Nee, mit Schlüsseln nicht.
Genau. Das wird wahrscheinlich, ich meine, das war dann halt vorher.
Aber sozusagen ab jetzt dürfen sie es halt nicht mehr, oder für alles ab jetzt
müssen sie es halt machen.
Und weil sie es nicht machen können, stellen sie diesen Dienst ein.
Ja, und Apple hat sich dann auch dazu geäußert, darf aber wegen dieser Gag-Order
halt nicht auf diese Verfügung verweisen.
Haben aber gesagt so, ja, wir können also jetzt diesen Dienst nicht mehr anbieten.
Und das wäre ja schön gewesen, weil da gibt es ja Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung,
und das wäre ja alles ganz vertrauenswürdig und so weiter.
Wir sind ja total enttäuscht, dass wir das nicht machen können,
weil es ja auch so viele Datenschutzverletzungen gibt und die Bedrohung der
Privatsphäre nimmt ständig zu.
Und das würden wir ja auch gerne verbessern und wir sind ja auch weiterhin bestrebt,
das alles ganz toll zu machen, auch in Zukunft im UK.
Und dann schließen Sie noch ab mit, wie wir schon oft gesagt haben,
haben wir nie eine Hintertür oder einen Generalschlüssel für eines unserer Produkte
oder Dienste eingebaut und werden dies auch nie tun.
Da kann man dann schon sehr zwischen den Zeilen lesen.
Genau, das ist so ein Canary in the Goldmine-Moment, wo sie halt sozusagen sagen, so ja, pfff.
Wir hätten ja, wir wollen ja nie einen Generalstuhl, wir wollen ja nie eine Backdoor einbauen.
Aber wir können jetzt in UK, können wir jetzt euch diesen Dienst leider nicht
anbieten. Kannst du selber zusammen reimen.
Ja, ist auch ganz interessant die Diskussion auf einer politischen Ebene jetzt mit Trump,
der ja quasi sich ja jetzt als der große Beschützer der IT-Unternehmen,
also zumindest derjenigen, die für seine Inaugurationsveranstaltung gespendet
haben und schön da rumgesessen haben, einsetzt.
Und quasi ja jetzt schon so Retaliation plant für, wenn böse andere Länder unseren
Unternehmen Vorschriften machen wollen,
dann gibt es was, Uwe Birner.
Da bin ich jetzt mal sehr gespannt, ob das diesen Teil auch erreicht oder nicht,
weil am Ende wäre ich auch nicht
überrascht, wenn sie dasselbe in den USA demnächst auch bald durchsetzen.
Das stimmt, ja. Aber Apple hat sich dagegen gewehrt, oder?
Also sie haben, versuchen es zumindest. ist.
Naja, ich meine, sie tun, was sie tun können und das ist halt,
das nicht anbieten, weil sie sind ja gezwungen.
Also ich meine, die Alternative wäre, dass sie den Markt komplett verlassen.
So.
Und ob ihren Kunden damit besser gedient ist, weiß ich nicht.
Eher nicht, weil dann musst du halt auf irgendwas anderes,
umsatteln, was auch nicht besser ist. Der Rest unterliegt ja denselben Bereichen.
Aber sehen wir, dass einfach eine politische Gesetzesentscheidung dazu führt,
dass eine Verbesserung von Datenschutz nicht mehr möglich ist.
Und das ist,
massenhafte Verschlüsselung von Dateien in der Cloud. Oder auch nur massenhaft zugänglich.
Es sind jetzt also viele Leute, wenn man das Advanced Data Protection anmacht,
da kommt schon auch eine ganze Menge Warnungen.
Da wird halt so gesagt, Junge, dann ist das weg.
Wenn du diesen Schlüssel dir
jetzt nicht merkst, dann ist das weg im schlimmsten Fall. Musst du wissen.
Aber es ist massenhaft zugänglich auf einem absoluten Konsumentengerät und noch
dazu, wenn du dich in diesem Apple-Ökosystem befindest,
das wird schon sehr, also du kannst diese Geräte ohne iCloud verwenden,
kannst du schon machen, aber richtig Sinn macht das nur mit.
Also dass du, vor allem wenn du jetzt mehrere Geräte hast, die Integration zwischen
jetzt einem Mac und einem iPhone und potenziell noch einem iPad,
dass die schön gleichzeitig zugänglich sind und die gleiche Fotolibrary und was nicht alles haben.
Und das ein Foto mit dem iPhone machst und eine Minute später auf dem Mac sehen kannst und so.
Das ist alles natürlich über einen Cloud-Dienst und eine Integration,
die, denke ich, bei Google ja in ähnlicher Form ist.
Und es gibt Handys, die das ohne machen, das ist alles richtig.
Aber gleichzeitig ist das zugänglich für.
Also das ist halt eine ordentliche also eine ausreichend gute Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung
für deine eigenen Daten bei einem Anbieter, dem du nicht vertrauen willst,
für die Breite der Bevölkerung oder eben nicht.
Und die Briten haben sich entschieden für oder eben nicht.
Genau.
Und da bleibt natürlich, niemand hindert dich daran, jetzt irgendein zusätzlich,
irgendein anderes. Das ist ja auch das Ding.
Also, bevor es das gab, habe ich
ja einfach irgendeinen anderen Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselungsding genutzt.
Ja, und habe was weiß ich, eCryptFS oder EncFS oder was auch immer für Dateien da reingeht.
Da gab es dann auch irgendeine Leute, die daraus einen Server gemacht haben,
einen Service gemacht haben.
Und dann hat es Apple irgendwann selber angeboten.
So sieht es aus.
Also Verschlüsselung nur noch für Kriminelle.
Genau. Falls ihr das noch nicht eingeschaltet habt, dann kann man das übrigens
raten, wenn ihr Nutzer seid vom Apple-Ökosystem.
Ist jetzt kein Feature, was einem die ganze Zeit um die Ohren gehauen wird,
weil daran verdienen sie ja nichts, aber man kann das halt einschalten.
Setzt allerdings voraus, dass man leidlich aktuelle Hardware in seinem Pool hat.
Also wenn man noch irgendein ganz altes Gerät auch in seinem iCloud-Account
noch mit drin hat, dann lässt sich das nicht einschalten, weil diese ganze Verschlüsselung,
nicht nur jetzt, da ist so Krypto am Start, sondern es setzt quasi auch eine bestimmte,
Kryptofähigkeit der Geräte voraus.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie vier, fünf Jahre irgendwie so in der
Größenordnung, wenn man noch älteres Gerät verwendet, dann lässt sich das glaube
ich noch nicht einschalten, das sagt er dann aber auch.
Ja,
Details.
Genau. So, jetzt gucken wir mal, was die Russen so können.
Ja, also das ist eine, also diese Nachricht muss man ein bisschen mit Vorsicht genießen,
weil sie von einem Unternehmen kommt mit dem Namen NewsGuard, die gibt es seit 2018.
Und die nehmen eine Bewertung von Nachrichtenseiten vor.
Und in den USA zum Beispiel haben sie, das ist jetzt vor einigen Jahren,
haben sie gesagt, wenn du 2000 Nachrichtenseiten quasi konsumieren,
bewerten und denen so einen Score geben.
Und dann kannst du halt irgendwie einen Browser-Plugin, dann wird gesagt,
hier, pass auf die Seite, das ist in Ordnung, wir haben in letzter Zeit regelmäßig
Wahrheiten gepostet oder hier, du bist auf bild.de oder so, oder das ist alles einfach nur Unsinn.
Und so sind die gestartet. Jetzt kommt natürlich KI und jetzt berichten die,
sie hätten also eine Studie gemacht, bei der sie feststellen,
dass sie Webseiten sehen.
Die gezielt auf Crawler ausgelegt sind und erkennbar weniger für menschliche Leser.
Und die würden vor allem Inhalte aus den russischen Staatsmedien und von kremlfreundlichen
Influencern bereitstellen, wiederholen und verstärken.
Und sie kommen zu dem Schluss,
dass es hier quasi um eine Multiplikatorwirkung durch häufiges Veröffentlichen
und Teilen dieser Inhalte erreicht werden soll in den Daten, in diesen Daten,
auf die mit denen künstliche Intelligenzen trainiert werden.
Und der Ansatz ist ja erstmal naheliegend.
Also wir kennen, als Suchmaschinen kamen, was ja so die,
wenn wir Suchmaschinen verstehen als Technologien, die in einem sehr unüberblickbaren
Datenraum uns helfen sollen, das zu finden, was wir suchen,
dann war natürlich die Search Engine Optimization.
Immer das Feld, die Inhalte so zu.
Dazu reichen, dass man in den Google Top Ten ist. Also ab Google Seite 2 ist ja Darknet.
Und das möchte man nicht.
Und die Weiterführung dieser Idee wäre natürlich jetzt, wenn es gar nicht mehr
darauf ankommt, also wenn wir demnächst in einer Welt leben,
in der die Leute meine Seite sowieso nicht mehr besuchen,
sondern ich durch bestimmte Wiederholungen von Fakten und Ansichten jetzt darauf
einwirken muss, dass eine KI das irgendwann glaubt und für wahr hält oder mit
größerer Wahrscheinlichkeit sagt,
dann wäre das quasi der logische nächste Schritt bei der Inhaltegenerierung für KIs.
Und die sagen, es gäbe also das russische Desinformationsnetzwerk Pravda,
die quasi das tun würden, um quasi sich anstrengend in das Repertoire der Trainingsdaten
aufgenommen zu werden, in der Echtzeitsuche genutzt zu werden.
Wir hätten 3,6 Millionen Artikel, die allein im Jahr 2024 mit diesem Ziel augenscheinlich
veröffentlicht wurden.
Und genau, das Unternehmen NewsGuard hat halt dieses Thema als Inhalt.
Es ist relativ verständlich, dass die sich damit in die Wahrnehmung bringen
möchten, natürlich auch.
Gleichzeitig ist der Ansatz natürlich absolut naheliegend und es ist auch wahrscheinlich,
also es ist jetzt nicht unglaubwürdig, dass das passiert,
dass man also versucht, auf die Lerninhalte einzugehen.
Einfluss zu nehmen. Was nicht so klar ist, ist, dass sie jetzt nachgewiesen
hätten, dass eine derartige, dass dieser Effekt auch erfolgreich wäre.
Also, dass man sagen könnte, hier, guck mal hier, die KI, der Chat-GPT,
mit dem der Donald Trump sich die Reden schreiben lässt oder so,
kein Wunder, dass das russlandfreundlich ist. Die Russen haben ja auch das Trainingsmaterial,
manipuliert. Ich fand es auf jeden Fall interessant, dass diese,
dass man jetzt Anzeichen für einen derartigen Ansatz findet.
Und wie gesagt, die Quelle ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zu genießen,
die wollen was verkaufen.
Naja gut, aber im Ergebnis sieht man das natürlich schon so.
Also Grock hier, diese AI da von Elon Musk, Die ist also schon sehr gut unterwegs
mit russischer Propaganda.
Ob das jetzt sozusagen Zufall ist oder Absicht, das sei mal für jeden selbst dahingestellt.
Trump hat jetzt irgendwie National Institute of Standards and Technology irgendwie dazu gezwungen,
jetzt hier Forschern vorzuschreiben, dass sie in AI jetzt irgendwie ideologischen
Bias aus ihren Modellen raushalten sollen.
Also viel Spaß.
Zensur sozusagen. Also das ist wirklich wild jetzt.
Also das ist, ich will jetzt nicht wieder so eine AI-Diskussion aufmachen,
aber es ist schon, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das nennen soll.
Also ich finde die Situation erschütternd, weil wir haben natürlich jetzt hier
so eine Vermischung von verschiedenen Trends,
die zu einem sehr unglücklichen Brei gerade zusammengerührt werden.
Auf der einen Seite haben wir eben diese Erfolge, sage ich jetzt mal,
in der Softwareentwicklung.
Diese Lösung des Problems von Intelligenz, die scheint ja ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Also man hat jetzt in den letzten Jahren nennenswerte Fortschritte gemacht und
es gibt ja viele, viele, viele gute Anwendungen für Deep Learning.
Und die ich auch gerne sehen will.
Also allein im medizinischen Bereich, was das für ein Potenzial hat in den letzten
Jahren Genforschung und so weiter, Krankheitsforschung, Medikamentenforschung,
Antivirus, alles mögliche. Also.
Unbegrenzte Möglichkeiten sehe ich da und das ist einfach etwas sehr, sehr, sehr Gutes.
Dann haben wir natürlich jetzt diese Popularität der Large Language Models,
deren Erfolg die Forscher selber ein bisschen überrascht hat.
Man hat halt festgestellt, das kann nicht nur gut Sprache verstehen und mehrere
Sprachen gleichzeitig verstehen und Konversationen führen, was das Ziel war.
Hence the name, Language Models, darum ging es sozusagen.
Und da aber in dieses ganze Training, was ja ein Training auf dem Internet war,
auf einer nicht unbegrenzt, aber sehr großen Datenbasis,
das war ja quasi eine der beiden Schrauben,
die so gelöst werden mussten, damit das überhaupt funktioniert.
Man hatte diese Methode des neuronales Netzwerks und des Deep Learnings,
die ist nicht ganz so neu.
Neu war nur, dass man ein paar Detailprobleme gelöst hat, Transformer Model und so weiter.
Da gab es so ein paar Papers, die halt so mit der Attention.
Attention is all you need, hieß ja das Paper von Geoffrey Hinton und dem anderen
Namen ist mir gerade entfallen, die gesagt haben so, ja, guck mal,
wenn du jetzt hier auf diesen Daten dein Deep Learning machst,
dann musst du irgendwie Attention anwenden.
Und das ist letzten Endes die Lösung für, welches Wort ist für was relevant.
Und das hat eben dazu geführt, dass diese Maschinen auf einmal in der Lage waren,
Text, Sprache so gut zu verstehen.
Und dadurch hat man sich ja quasi auf dem ganzen Datenmodell des Internets trainiert,
weil da ist ja viel Sprache.
Aber in dieser Sprache ist halt auch Wissen. Und dieses Wissen bildete sich
dann eben auch in diesen Language Models mit ab.
Und das war ja so ein bisschen der eigentliche Schocker. Also dass die Dinger so gut.
Dass die ja deutsch und japanisch und chinesisch und schwedisch und koreanisch
und baskisch gleichzeitig können, das scheint ja überhaupt keinen zu interessieren.
Das finde ich ja irgendwie das eigentlich Bemerkenswerte dabei,
dass quasi der Bubble-Fisch erfunden wurde.
Aber viel interessanter war natürlich, dass diese Systeme sich auf einmal eigneten,
eben das Weltwissen zumindest halbwegs brauchbar, nicht immer richtig,
aber zumindest schon so viel.
Das Weltwissen nicht immer richtig?
Weil es nie darum ging. Diese Modelle waren nie, sind es auch heute nicht.
Das sind keine Wissensmaschinen. Es sind keine Knowledge Center.
Es sind keine Auskunftteilen, es sind keine Bibliotheken.
Es ist nichts. Im Prinzip ist das so eine Art komprimiertes Internet.
Das ist wie so eine ZIP-Datei vom Internet, wo du in reduzierten Daten möglichst
viel dieses Wissens hast.
Aber eigentlich geht es um das Wissen von Sprache als solcher.
Und was sich aber auch darin abbildet, ist das Wissen, was diese Sprache beschrieb.
Die fällt da quasi automatisch mit raus. Und durch dieses Prompting kann man
eben diese Attention so legen,
dass eben dieses Wissen, was da drin steckt, was eigentlich mehr so eine Art
kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung ist in diesen Daten,
dass das auch noch mit nach vorne kommt.
Aber deswegen ist es halt mal so, mal so.
Und jetzt haben natürlich alle gesehen, oh wow, alle stürzen sich auf diese LLMs.
Es gibt jetzt ein paar Verrückte, die sind der Meinung, man kann das komplette
Ministerium in den USA auflösen und durch irgendwie AI ersetzen.
Da gab es jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen, was war das, irgendwie in dem Health-Ministerium
oder irgendwo, wo haben sie irgendwie die komplette Softwareabteilung irgendwie
gekündigt, weil sie meinten, das können wir jetzt alles mit AI machen.
Und haben dann irgendwie ganz stolz ihre AI demonstriert.
Ja, hier, wir brauchen jetzt gar keine Programmierer mehr, wir können jetzt
hier die Webseiten, können wir automatisch generieren lassen.
Demo gemacht und dann stand da so, welcome to our company.
So läuft das. Da rennen auch gerade ein paar Leute ordentlich gegen die Wand.
Aber der Hype ist ja real. So, und worauf ich hinaus will, ist,
jetzt mischt sich das mit diesem,
Den globalen Verkehrsunfall, Trump.
Idiocracy in real, die Dummheit,
Stupidity ist jetzt so groß geworden in unserer Gesellschaft,
nichts mehr ist wichtig, nichts mehr ist real, alles ist egal.
Es geht nur noch darum, ich, ich, ich und die anderen sind böse.
Hauptsache gegen Vogue, Hauptsache
gegen alles, was ich hasse und der Rest interessiert mich nicht.
Und keiner soll mir in mein Ich-Bild hineinreden, schon gar nicht der Staat.
Und da kommt dann so ein Trump und sagt, ich mach das mal alles.
Und hinter ihm die ganze Herrschaft von so technikgläubigen Wahnsinnigen,
die irgendwie diese Singularität anstreben, irgendwie Weltherrschaft,
Freedom Cities und diesen ganzen Scheiß hinter sich herziehen.
Und die Russen stehen da und sagen so, ah, ihr wollt also jetzt den AIs glauben.
Na super, wir wollen ja ruhig die ganze Zeit, dass ihr unseren Scheiß glaubt.
Und Propaganda ist halt nicht ohne Grund ein russisches Wort.
Das können die halt richtig gut.
Und die beschäftigen sich auch mit dem Internet schon etwas länger intensiver.
Ich meine, du hast schon so viele lustige Security-Stories erzählt.
Bitcoin-Erpressung und so weiter. Also das findet nicht immer alles in Russland
statt, aber viel findet in Russland statt.
Und der Staat ist dort schon seit Jahrzehnten dabei, große Mengen an Geld in
Organisationen reinzustecken, die im Prinzip Kriminelle beschäftigen.
Das heißt, es gibt da so eine Staatskriminalität, die sich auch im Internet abspielt.
Da gibt es auch in Nordkorea, damit machen die im Wesentlichen ihr Geld,
mit dem sie dann ihre Atombomben bauen, mit dem sie halt allen Leuten Bitcoins wegnehmen.
Und Russland will aber vor allem die Zerstörung des Westens vorantreiben,
indem sie quasi dieses Meme mit alles, nichts, niemand glaubt überhaupt irgendjemand noch irgendwas.
Das ist sozusagen ihre Methode. Die vollständige Zerstörung des Diskurses.
Weil ein informierter intellektueller Diskurs ist die Zerstörung der Demokratie
und die Demokratie ist der größte Dorn im Auge für alle Leute,
die viel Macht und Geld haben.
Weil Demokratie stört einfach nur.
Demokratie ist anstrengend und schwierig und dann wollen die anderen auch noch alle irgendwie was.
So und jetzt gehen sie halt vor und sagen, ah okay gut, also das Internet,
das wird also die ganze Zeit jetzt durchforscht nach neuen Wahrheiten und das
nehmen wir jetzt mit rein.
Und ich muss, gerade habe ich so gesagt, die haben den Nachweis nicht geführt,
dass dieses Wissen auch in den Chatbots landet.
Das muss ich ein bisschen korrigieren, relativieren, was ich damit genau meinte.
Also sie nennen hier zum Beispiel ein Beispiel,
wo man sagt, sie haben Chatbots gefragt, warum hat Zelensky Trump Truth.Social sperren lassen?
Und dann werden als Antwort Gründe genannt, die sich in derartigen Artikeln befinden.
Die Realität ist, Selenskyj hat nie Truth.Social sperren lassen.
Ja, also sie das Beispiel, was sie hier nennen ist, du gibst schon quasi was
Falsches ein und er korrigiert dich nicht.
Was auch schon mal schlimm ist, aber quasi sagen aber nicht,
du gehst da rein und sagst, was ist eigentlich mit Zelensky und der Chatbot
sagt dir, weiß ich nicht, faschistischer.
Typ, der da irgendwie Teile von Russland besetzt oder was auch immer,
eine russische Agency sie potenziell eigentlich sagen würde.
Also das Beispiel, was sie nennen, ich will das gar nicht runterspielen.
Und es ist natürlich hier ein Fall von Fake News.
Das wäre die Gelegenheit gewesen, dass die KI dich korrigiert,
wenn du da irgendwie Unsinn redest.
Und diesen Inhalt, Selenskyj habe Truth.Social irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Zankereien,
mit Trump sperren lassen,
das findet sich eben in diesen Artikeln also sie haben schon einen Nachweis
auch für, dass sich diese Inhalte dann auch wieder in dem Modell finden und dass sie nicht wahr sind,
und wenn man diese Unwahrheiten behauptet, man auch nicht korrigiert wird also,
ja, also der Effekt ist zumindest nachweisbar ja,
Weil ich gerade den Eindruck erweckt habe in meiner Äußerung,
dass er nicht nachweisbar wäre.
Ja, wobei, das passt insofern auch ganz gut zu dem, was ich vorher gesagt habe.
Ich versuche es halt.
Ja, also ja, aber auch, dass du schon die falsche Frage stellst,
ist ja schon etwas, mit dem du auch heute problemlos auch auf korrekten Daten
trainierte LLMs aus dem Tritt bringen kannst.
Weil es geht ja nicht bei den LLMs der heutigen Generation.
Und wenn du da eine Frage stellst, dann ist das ja nicht so,
oh, hier wurde eine Frage gestellt, ich muss die Wahrheit herausfinden,
sondern, oh, hier ist ein Blurb of Text,
den muss ich jetzt mal sozusagen weitererzählen auf Basis der Daten, die ich habe.
Und wenn du halt insistierst und sagst, erkläre mir ausführlich,
wie es dazu kommen konnte, dass eine isländische Fußballmannschaft drei Wochen
auf dem Mond überleben konnte,
wie es in zahlreichen Griechen belegt wurde und wie wir ja alle wissen und so weiter,
dann wird sich die LLM ein Bein ausreißen, alles irgendwie herbeizufantasieren,
was in irgendeiner Form diese Story stützen könnte.
Weil du ja klar gemacht hast, dass das ja die Wahrheit ist und jetzt brauchst du ja nur noch den Rest.
Und genau daran scheitert das. Und deswegen ist das gerade, deswegen meinte ich,
wir sind deswegen gerade in so einem unglücklichen Moment Crossroads,
wo wir politischen Machtmissbrauch, braucht,
technologisches Aufstreben einer wirklich nützlichen,
potenziellen, sehr nützlichen Technologie mit hohem Missverständnispotenzial
haben und einer Gesellschaft,
die schon mit dem Internet an sich Schwierigkeiten hat, klarzukommen.
Und was wirklich nur noch von sehr wenigen Leuten wirklich verstanden wird,
was da eigentlich gerade passiert.
Und deswegen ist das alles so dramatisch scheiße gerade,
was hier abgeht, weil wir natürlich jetzt Leute am Hebel der Macht haben in
den USA, die das alles wissen, aber die gerade auch alles daran setzen,
alles zu ihrem persönlichen Vorteil auszuschlachten, auf der einen Seite und
auf der anderen Seite hast du China und Russland, also die Chinesen betrifft das genauso,
die die einfach Informationspumpen am Start haben im industriellen Maßstab.
Gerade gelesen, irgendein Open-Source-Provider, die irgendwie Git-Programm-Code-Seiten anbieten.
Die Admins schwitzen gerade richtig,
weil irgendwas zwischen 93 und 97 Prozent des Traffics, der auf ihre Webseiten einhämmert,
sind irgendwelche AI-Crawler, Crawler, die das ganze Internet abfangen und während
es noch ein paar brave gibt in den USA, die sagen,
hallo, ich bin der Crawler von dieser AI und ich würde jetzt hier gerne mal
deine Webseite durchlesen,
ist es wohl mittlerweile bei den chinesischen Bots so,
dass die so Crawler haben, die mit jedem einzelnen Zugriff von einer anderen IP-Adresse,
mit einem anderen Webbrowser da drin und so weiter kommen, also die mischen
das alles permanent durch, um auf gar keinen Fall in irgendeiner Form durch
irgendwelche Filter zu kommen, die halten sich natürlich an.
Keinerlei Ablehnung und so weiter und die Systeme, die auch jetzt schon existieren,
es ist schlimm genug, dass man sowas braucht, die quasi so AI-Bot-Detection
machen und sagen so, ja, nee, bitte weitergehen, hier gibt es nichts zu sehen,
die sind halt auch total überfordert.
Also, Leute haben derzeit teilweise im Admin-Bereich nichts anderes mehr zu
tun, als sich nur noch diesen scheiß AI-Kack vom Hals zu halten und vorher war
es ja schon so, dass das Internet,
allein auf Security-Sicherheitslücken die ganze Zeit abgetastet wurde und jetzt
kommt halt dieser ganze Web-Scheiß noch oben dazu. Das ist wirklich zum Kotzen.
Und alles, was schön ist, wird kaputt gemacht gerade und es macht gar keinen Spaß mehr.
Okay, aber hey, Timmy, das muss ja auch mal, also,
du hättest ruhig auch auf eine etwas positive Note enden können.
Wir haben ja noch ein Thema, oder?
Nee, haben wir nicht mehr.
Deswegen also.
Sorry. Bei mir ist da gerade echt nichts zu holen.
Mal schauen. In der Woche bin ich wieder in Deutschland. Vielleicht bessert es sich dann da.
Ich habe während des Spraßes Chad Gipitin nach der Fußballmannschaft gefragt, der isländischen.
Und?
Wurde in Ruhe ausge... es wurde so, haha, das klingt nach einer sehr schönen Fantasiegeschichte.
Also es gab schon den Hinweis und als ich diese Selensky-Nummer fragte,
hat er auch gesagt, diese Berichte sind falsch.
Also ich will, das ist jetzt hier, was weiß ich, welches Chat-GPT-Modell das jetzt wieder ist.
Ich denke, das widerlegt jetzt auch nicht,
Die grundsätzliche Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das passiert. Und ich weiß zum Beispiel
auch nicht, wenn ich jetzt hier andere Modelle launche, was die mir antworten.
Ich habe hier mit dem, wie heißt das, DeepSeek, das habe ich hier mal so lokal laufen.
Da kommt wirklich in der Regel sehr großer Quatsch bei raus.
Da kann ich überhaupt nicht die Überzeugung mit dem Modell feststellen.
Allerdings habe ich auch nur das kleinere mit sieben Billionen,
glaube ich. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, da ist nicht viel Wissen drin.
Die kleinen Modelle haben schon Probleme mit Sprache. Das ist ja auch ein permanenter Krieg.
Natürlich sind ja auch sowohl OpenAI als auch, ich weiß auch,
dass Anthropic sehr viel Energie drauf schmeißt,
ihre Systeme in Anführungsstrichen sicher zu machen, wobei da glaube ich mehr
von Safety die Rede ist als von Security.
Da gibt es ja diese schöne Unterscheidung im Englischen, die wir so im Deutschen nicht haben.
Also, dass da alles safe ist. Und die sind auch etwas zurückhaltender beim Rausfeuern
neuer Modelle, bevor sie nicht allen Kriterien entsprochen haben.
Es gibt jetzt nicht nur zwei Modelle, sondern es gibt mittlerweile viele, es gibt viele große.
Wir haben von Meta, wir haben DeepSeek, wir haben Quen von Alibaba und ich glaube
Tencent ist jetzt irgendwie auch ganz dick dabei.
Also die von TikTok, alle großen Tech-Unternehmen bauen da was.
Und das Problem wird sicherlich irgendwo auf der einen Seite immer bekämpft
werden, nur das hat so seine Grenzen.
Und mit einer Technologie, die so schwer in den Griff zu bekommen ist.
Weil du ja hier durch diese Kompression, durch diese Verhäschung der Welt,
kannst du gar nichts wirklich präzise machen. Weil da gibt es keine klaren Algorithmen.
Du kannst da tausend Prompts dahinter schmeißen mit, ja, aber wenn so gefragt
wird, dann sag mal nix dazu.
Die haben alle so, ja, was weiß ich, wenn du jetzt über Selbstmord redest oder
wenn du jetzt irgendwie über Weltumsturz oder Terrorismus und Bombenbau,
da haben sie dann irgendwo so einen Unterlehrer, der versucht,
das irgendwie rauszufiltern.
Aber du kannst es halt immer irgendwie umgehen. Du kannst sagen,
ich rede jetzt mit dir nur noch in Morsecode und dann greifen auf einmal diese
Filter nicht mehr und so. Und das ist so das eigentliche Problem.
Und was auch noch dran hängt an dieser ganzen Geschichte, haben wir jetzt gar
nicht so nach vorne gestellt, ist natürlich diese Beballerung des Webs mit Slop.
Also es gibt so viele Webseiten, die einfach wirklich nur dafür da sind, Quatsch zu erzählen.
Du kannst fast gar nichts mehr, du kannst nichts mehr, ich hätte fast gesagt,
man kann nichts mehr glauben im Internet. Er hat nichts mehr glauben.
Was im Internet steht.
Als ob das jemals schon mal anders war. Quelle Internet. Der alte Witz.
Ja, wunderschön, Tim. Sind wir am Ende der Quelle.
Mehr hat die Quelle heute nicht
hergegeben. Wir wollten eine kurze Sendung machen. Ist auch mal schön.
Ja, ist auch mal schön. Lorde. Ja. Haben wir noch irgendwas zu berichten? Nö.
Nee, vorbei. Nichts mehr.
Kommende Sendungen dann jetzt wieder ohne Zeitzonen-Unterschied. Erstmal.
Weißt du schon, wenn du zurück nach Deutschland kommst?
Ja, weiß ich schon.
Wann denn?
In einer Woche.
In einer Woche. Ja.
Könnt ihr euch schon mal darauf freuen.
Auch wenn es keinen Unterschied macht.
Okay, Leute. Bis bald. Das war's. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.